i have to go to the bathroom
i said all right
you gotta go you're gonna go the movie
based on mario puzo's best-selling novel
the godfather is considered one of the
best ever made and has inspired books
articles and documentaries veteran
writer mark seal gained access to some
of the key figures involved in both the
book and the film his new book is leave
the gun take the cannoli a title based
on an ad-lib line from the film seal
writes that real-life mobsters at first
dreaded then revered the movie leave the
gun
take the cannoli see you'll gain access
to author mario puzo's personal notes
and archives and goes into detail about
the many unlikely names considered for
movie roles i mean robert redford was
mentioned for the michael corleone part
right exactly robert redford was one
ryan o'neal who was in love story for
paramount which was a huge hit for
paramount was considered as michael but
the big big big big uh battle was over
marlon brando nobody wanted marlon
brando except for puzzle novelist mario
puzo was an inveterate gambler who lost
a fortune at las vegas casinos while
supposedly doing research on the
mobsters who controlled organized crime
leave the gun take the cannoli the epic
story behind the making of the godfather
on mysterywire.com
you